For more than 40 years, CNN has offered
a front row
seat to history in the making.
Why am I under arrest?
It's a hoax set up.
Join us
as we turn back the clock to expose
Osama bin Laden
and watch the stories
that have defined our time
There are no words to say O.J.
Simpson
This is CNN's Rewind
It was January 19.
86 Americans had just been introduced
to Nintendo.
Back to the Future was in theaters
and the Cold War
was beginning to warm up.
Meanwhile, NASA's shuttle program
was bringing the dream of space travel
closer to home.
Here today to announce the first private
citizen passenger
in the history of space flight.
But on a cold January morning,
disaster would ground the ambitions
of spaceflight for years to come
to one and
the space race began in
earnest after World War Two.
Both the United States
and the Soviet Union
perfected rockets and missiles
from the beginning.
The space program was more
than a scientific experiment.
It was a matter of national pride
and national security.
With the U.S. on top of the space race.
Now, so let military considerations
take a backseat
and concentrated on science.
But now Congress
wanted a return
on their space investment.
Billions of dollars
had been poured
into the national project.
The seventies found national researchers
back to the drawing board,
working almost nonstop
to develop this space vehicle
that could be launched into space
and returned much like an airplane
on November 24th. 1980.
The first space shuttle
rolled out of the hangar.
Its name, Columbia.
It marked a new era in space exploration.
Since then, three other shuttle crafts
have been built.
Challenger, Discovery and Atlantis
Today, I'm directing Nelson
to begin
a search
in all of our elementary
and secondary schools
and to choose
as the first citizen passionate
passenger in the history
of our space program.
One of America's finest, a teacher
applications
to be the first civilian in space
will be distributed through all U.S.
public, private and parochial schools.
Nassau officials will select
one civilian astronaut
and one backup
for several months of preflight training.
The teacher who will be going into space,
Christa McAuliffe, first said, You
make all of the space for training.
She clearly relished the challenge.
She said she hoped to inspire others
to reach out
and try new and different things.
One of the things that I would like to do
when I go aboard
the shuttle is to bring
back the wonder of it all.
To see
McAuliffe like a wrecking yard
or something,
you know, floating around in space
First it was the wind.
Then it was a frozen bolt.
Then it was the wind again.
As a result, the space
shuttle Challenger is still sitting on
launch pad 39 B
at the Kennedy Space Center.
The weather once again
ruining NASA's show
but the country's
space agency has learned in recent weeks,
as well as the rest of us, is
that this is a difficult
general time of year
to try and launch a space shuttle.
Patience has been a key element
around the nascent operation
all this week.
We're going to join
Tom Mintier now at once again
just getting down about 3 minutes.
And they think they can do it.
They are counting.
The ice is cleared away
and Challenger should be going away
very soon.
Let's go down to the Kennedy Space Center
and take a look at Challenger
sitting on the pad
as they continue the countdown.
They started the auxiliary power units
about a minute ago
and that is one of the major
milestones to continuing the countdown
and counting. Gimble checks now complete
U.S.
military operations.
They have external tank,
liquid oxygen, pressurization has started
and purging of the shuttle main
engines is terminated.
I hope it takes off this time.
Let's go
through some
more checks now.
Complete
during the six days in space,
the astronauts are going to release
a $100 million satellite
and another one called Haley Spartan
that will study the comet.
But the highlight on this mission
is the including
in the flight of Christa McAuliffe,
a 37 year old high school
social studies teacher from Concord
New Hampshire.
She will teach from space on Friday.
Now, if they are able to get off today,
they will have live coverage here on CNN
of her
giving lessons
to students on the ground here helping.
T-minus 15 seconds, please go.
I want it to
be known as cameras
nine or eight, seven, six.
We have main engine start
for three, two, one.
And lift on liftoff of the 25th space
shuttle mission.
And it has cleared the tower,
a controlling program
right on the challenger
the good roll program confirmed
Challenger now heading downrange
Engines beginning
throttling now now at 94% normal throttle
for most of the plane 204%
will throttle down to 65%
shortly
engines at
65% three engines
running normally three good fuel cells
three good APUs
velocity 257 feet per second altitude
4.3 nautical miles downrange
distance three nautical miles
So the 25th space shuttle mission
is now on the way.
After more
delays, the NASA cares
to count this morning.
That looked as though
they were not going to be able to get off
One minute, 15 seconds velocity.
2900 feet per
second altitude, nine nautical miles
downrange, distance, seven nautical miles
It looks like a couple
of the solid rocket boosters
blew away from the side of the shuttle
in an explosion
Flight controllers
here are looking
very carefully at the situation.
Obviously, a major malfunction
We have no downlink
please.
For instance,
you have the explosion on tape.
Yes. Hi.
Oh, my goodness.
We're awaiting word.
They're holding their breath.
Just I'm sure, as everyone else is.
You saw just a few moments ago
about 45 seconds after liftoff,
a huge fireball in the sky.
We have a report from the Flight
Dynamics officer
that the vehicle has exploded
flight director confirms
that we are looking at
checking with the recovery forces to see
what can be done at this point.
Contingency procedures are
in effect
in what appears to be
a major catastrophe
in America's space program.
Challenger
only seconds
after leaving the launch pad,
according to NASA,
has exploded in midair.
No word yet on
if there are any survivors.
You can see what appears to be a ship
off of the Kennedy Space Center.
Just saw a splash in the water.
Don't know if that was one of the solid
rocket boosters or part of the
shuttle
on board the space shuttle this morning.
Commander Francis Dick Scobee,
copilot Michael Smith
Judith Resnick,
Ronald McNair,
Jeffrey Jarvis and Christa McAuliffe
and Ellison Azuka
Let's take another look now.
Just seconds, seconds into the launch.
This is before the solid rockets were lit
T-minus and go, man, or eight,
seven, six.
We have main engine start for 32,
one, and liftoff.
Liftoff of the 21st space
shuttle mission.
And it is clear as the tower
controlling program
right around the challenger
control program confirmed
the challenger now heading downrange
Tom, everything looks normal
to this point.
I don't want to say it again.
Everything looks normal to this point.
It's one
the long range tracking here on down now
took over
and you could see an extreme close up
as the
solid rocket boosters
appeared to throttle down
to be breaking away from the shuttle
and then explode.
It comes up in just a few seconds here
and again,
running normally
there.
You can see
right before the explosion velocity,
the external tank,
it attaches to the shuttle.
The flame appeared to break out
between the external tank
and the shuttle.
Time.
This has never happened before.
I know you are aware
that there are contingency plans for such
such an event
because it's never happened before.
I think
possibly many people even involved
are not aware of what they are.
Do they have ships standing by?
There are recovery ships standing by
and they do go through
procedures for launch aborts.
There is a worst case scenario.
We have CNN's John Zarrella
at the Kennedy Space Center
on the live line now.
John, you could,
I'm sure,
see it from your vantage point,
even nine miles down.
Describe the scene there.
Here now
it's at the Kennedy Space Center.
Everybody is just stunned.
They're in shock.
It's a situation
where people are just
sort of standing around and,
you know,
just bewilderment at this point.
And,
of course,
we're not getting any information
from here
any more than what you are, only
just what we have just witnessed
and what seen as tragic, tragic incident
with the explosion that we saw
just a few minutes ago.
We're back now
to a live picture from a helicopter above
the launch area.
This is Mission Control in Houston.
For the last four or 5 minutes.
The audio channel from Mission
Control has been silent.
Not a single word has been spoken.
While the rescue efforts,
if there are any to be
made, are underway.
Let's go to the White House
now and Larry speaks and shocked
at what he is just seeing replayed
on television
concerning the shuttle launch.
We do not have any more information
than it is being provided to the
public at this time.
The way the first person
found out about it is
he was in the Oval Office.
The vice president
and the foreign policy adviser,
John Poindexter, came in with others
and informed the president
that the news had just broken.
We immediately
adjourned our Oval Office
meeting and went into an adjoining room.
The president study
where there's a television.
And the president then began to review
television reports of the explosion there
shortly after the launch.
So once again,
the president is as concerned.
He is is is saddened.
He is very anxious
to have more information on it
at the moment, as I say,
we're learning most of our information
from what the public is getting
everything said
about the fact
that the teacher was on board this plane.
Well, it was something that was
it was on all of our minds that
that we did have the first teacher
in space, really, the first
civilian, so
to speak,
other than our members of Congress
who have flown in space.
And it certainly that's on our mind.
Tom, we've just learned from a
wire report
that the students at Christa McAuliffe
High School in New Hampshire
were watching the lift off,
along with hundreds of thousands
of other Americans.
Students filled the Concord High School
Auditorium to watch the launch.
As Challenger lifted off,
they shouted Clap Blue horns.
At first, few realized what had happened.
Then the fact that what began
as a joyous event
had turned to tragedy hit them.
They said on TV that it blew up
and everybody started crying.
And that's when I
realized what happened.
The word of the Challenger catastrophe
struck Washington
like a winter thunderbolt.
The House of Representatives
was in session
at 1138 Eastern Time this morning,
but not for long.
The House
chaplain and very quickly
upon learning of the news,
offered a prayer for those off
the coast of Florida.
James Ford presented the wishes
and the will of the House
to a chilled and cold
House of Representatives.
And at this special
moment, let us remember in silent prayer,
those who were involved in the spacecraft
shuttle accident
just a few minutes ago of Florida.
Let us pray
then the speaker, Tip O'Neill, a drive.
When we come back to you,
I want to take a pause
for 10 seconds of silence.
We'll go to what,
a 14 and 10 seconds of silence
and you can say that
if you want challenger
as far as it affects
the nation's capital.
Now, Bob,
thank you, Richard.
And we will pause now
at CNN in our coverage for 10 seconds
of silence
3 minutes before launch time.
Correspondent
Tom Mintier
joined us on the set
to begin our live coverage of the launch
of the only concern that
that Nasser
really showed
this morning was with the icicles,
some of them two foot long
and it might be proper to go back
and look
and think about the situation with that.
They were very concerned.
They called an emergency meeting
at the John
Kennedy Space Center to discuss
whether the ice on the pad area
could possibly damage
the shuttle on liftoff.
NASA's has never gone through ice
in the launch pad area before.
And they decided at that meeting
that it posed no danger
and they went ahead with the countdown
Associate Administrator
Jess, more previously,
when pressured about Nasser
being so far
behind schedule
this year,
already with two missions only flown
stated emphatically that we will never
compromise safety standards for schedule.
Those were his words,
just a few days ago.
Charles, of course,
the president has a public duty
to perform tonight
his State of the Union address at nine
Eastern Time.
It seems does it not almost inevitable
that this is going to cast
a long and mournful
shadow over even that?
Well, the president had hoped to make
the kind of speech
that it was being described
here as a visionary, laying out his hopes
for this country
through the end to the next century.
I think it is fair to guess, in fact, Mr.
Speaker, sort of indicated
that the president would be compelled
to have something to say
about this tragedy.
And I think we will hear that tonight.
Yes, it does
indeed cast a pall on this event.
And among the Americans
who saw the devastation
that struck America's space program
and seven people aboard
the space
shuttle were the husband of 37 year
old New Hampshire schoolteacher
Christa McAuliffe
and her nine year old daughter
also at the Cape, or just actually three
and a half miles from the Cape,
watching as it happened this morning,
where Christa McAuliffe,
two parents, Edward and Grace Corrigan,
were watching from a VIP area
some three and a half miles away.
The wire services are reported
to observing, the two of them
hugging and sobbing
as they saw
the explosion aboard the shuttle.
These are the spectators
that were watching
shortly
after
that.
65%, three engine running
normally during the fuel cells,
particularly the use
three.
253%. Now,
this is raw, unedited video just
sent via satellite
They're just throwing up the
challenger going.
Right lot of pictures
you were just seeing
as Christa McAuliffe, the parents
watching in horror.
These are the students from her school
here looking very
carefully situation.
Obviously literally unconscious.
Many of them
probably had their view blocked
just as we did
with the television cameras
with just a
huge fireball and a huge cloud of smoke.
They may not realize yet
what has happened.
They go wherever
you see concern etched on their faces,
the breath
that they've been holding released.
And then the realization sets in
that something is wrong
I think that that shows
you apart
from on stage, you know, part
yeah.
At that point,
all that remained will play dynamics.
After that, the vehicle was exploded
over into a commercial
that we're looking at
whether recovery process to see
what can be done at that point.
Simply as the procedures
are so
let's get it right
or or at least feel
the
families of the astronauts
normally in the grandstand
And
Tom, as John
Zarrella pointed out
from the cave earlier,
when all of us first saw the blast
and there was a moment of
of stunned silence and disbelief,
many people
perhaps did confuse it with the.
Is it the booster rock solid
rocket booster separation?
But it was a little later,
it was far too early
and far
too big
an explosion of
Tom, the area that we were just watching.
That is the VIP
section, invited guests for this launch
I myself received an invitation
from Michael Smith,
who was the pilot on this flight,
to sit in these same bleachers
and to watch his launch.
Michael Smith has been a guest here
on CNN before on our launch coverage.
And he sent me a special invitation to go
that would then
include family members of the astronauts
and it includes family
members, schoolchildren
from New Hampshire or
ladies and gentlemen,
I plan
to speak to you tonight to report
on the State of the Union
for the events of earlier
today have led me to change those plans.
Today is a day for mourning
and remembering
19 years ago, almost to the day,
we lost three astronauts
in a terrible accident on the ground.
But we've never lost
an astronaut in flight.
We've never had a tragedy like this.
And perhaps
we've forgotten the courage
it took for the crew of the shuttle.
But they the Challenger
seven, were aware of the dangers,
but overcame them
and did their jobs brilliantly.
We mourn seven heroes.
We mourn their loss as a nation together.
The families of the seven,
we cannot bear, as you do,
the full impact of this tragedy.
But we feel the loss
and we're thinking about you.
So very much.
Your loved ones were daring and brave,
and they had that special grace,
a special spirit
that says, give me a challenge
and I'll need it with joy.
They had a hunger to explore the universe
and discover its truths
they wished to serve.
And they did.
They served all of us
And I want to say something
to the schoolchildren of America
who were watching the live coverage
of the shuttle's takeoff.
I know it's hard to understand,
but sometimes painful
things like this happen.
It's all part of the process
of exploration and discovery.
It's all part of
taking a chance
and expanding man's horizons.
The future doesn't
belong to the fainthearted.
It belongs to the brave.
The Challenger crew
was pulling us into the future
and we'll continue to follow them
The shuttle's busiest schedule ever
will be delayed
while investigators
figure out what went wrong
The challenger would have flown
successfully if the weather at Cape
Canaveral had been warm.
Massa was not communicating with itself
and was keeping some problems
secret from top management.
Westbrook
himself.
There are no words today.
History.
United States.
Osama bin Laden. Explosion.
Donald Trump.
Wins a hoax, etc..
Why am I under arrest?